c'est une journée de casse-tête
aujourd'hui on va faire un casse-tête
qui s'appelle qui s'appelle comment
d'ailleurs un indice
un indice là c'est plus qu'un indice
ouais
le casse-tête 5 sur 6 faisable dans 30
minutes à une heure il est mignon
[Applaudissements]
phase d'observation c'est un chat mignon
fin de la phase d'observation on a les
oreilles qui bougent les yeux ont l'air
de pouvoir bouger le nez il bouge
véritablement et là on voit qu'il y a
deux parties aussi qui ont un petit peu
de jeu tout le reste a l'air vraiment
solidaire c'est à dire que le reste du
ouais on est ensemble les gars
le but de ce casse-tête qui apparemment
est suivant les sites entre 4 sur 6 et 5
sur 6 c'est de trouver un petit bonbon
japonais dont je n'ai plus le nom c'est
pas un vrai bonbon évidemment qui est à
l'intérieur mais c'est une
représentation de ça qui serait cachée à
l'intérieur du chat quelque part donc on
va voir les premières actions je pense
que c'est un séquentiel pas
exponentielle exponentielle c'est ça
tac
séquentiel c'est quand tu dois faire une
étape après l'autre et tant que tu as
pas fait la prochaine étape tu es bloqué
tout ça a commencé par le nez c'est le
seul truc qui bouge
oh on a une petite oreille qui rentre là
on était comme ça tac là ça rentre on a
de le faire faut crever les yeux du chat
j'ai l'impression
je te jure ça fait un peu
je sais pas si tu m'as cassé le truc ou
si c'est la suite ah si c'est peut-être
ça lâcher ouais vas-y cherche la
prochaine étape viens
de montage dans la vidéo j'ai eu un
commentaire comme ça qui m'a dit trop de
montage dans les vidéos c'est parti
alors ça j'ai fait ça ah et là on peut
remarquer ça ça bouge oh attends mais
c'est génial parce que là ça fait ça et
là je peux tirer cette oreille là pas
mal est-ce qu'on peut la tirer avant
tu as trouvé une autre étape
[Musique]
c'est que je vous ai pas trop quoi faire
néanmoins
et ben voilà oui alors ouais attends
je suis je suis sur le sur le coup là
mon gars t'inquiète je fais ça
ça fait ça si j'appuie là comment je
pourrais enlever plus est-ce que ce
serait un truc avec ce truc qui tourne
où il y aurait une autre
clé truc en fait pour le montage
vraiment là vraiment là ma tête moi je
sais très bien que
développement de montage donc ça c'est
quand on tourne le nez du chat et là il
y a son oreille qu'on appuie là
oui ça enclenche ça on peut tirer
l'oreille et aller un peu plus loin mais
après on est keblo ok c'est pour toi là
c'est casse-tête Slayer
ici on a un œil ici on a un chat on a
fait le point non mais là il y a un trou
là il faut faire un truc dans ce trou il
y a un truc effectivement il y a un trou
ah il y a un petit aimant non bah ouais
ici là il y a un trou et au bout
attendez attendez attendez démantelation
au bout donc toi qu'est-ce que tu penses
qu'il faut faire Fabien
ça marche pas c'est comment il est tenu
ce truc
là-dedans
qu'est-ce que je viens de faire
ou j'ai cassé le casse-tête oh qu'est-ce
qu'il y a derrière qu'est-ce que c'est
ça Loïc un petit aimant c'est un petit
aimant et ça ferait pas plus poil la
taille de notre trousse j'ai bien
l'impression que si
alors
j'appuie dessus et là il se passe bien
il se passe bien rien là
c'est pas bête
là forcément si j'appuie ça fera rien
puisque il est en transverse oh là j'ai
tiré un truc par contre
faut qu'on regarde le mécanisme mais non
c'est un chat tu vois on l'a mis là
comme ça par le trou et après on a tiré
comme ça chaque et ça ça donc j'imagine
qu'il doit y avoir un trou derrière
l'oeil ah oui d'accord l'oeil il est
tenu pareil par des aimants
du coup qu'est-ce qu'on fait là
il y a plus trop d'éléments amovibles
[Musique]
[Rires]
sans les yeux peut-être que ça permet
d'enclencher un truc j'en sais rien
[Rires]
on peut lever par contre regarde on peut
le on peut lever le nez ah il y a un
trou au fond est-ce qu'on va le trou du
fond là c'est
lui mais attends mais attends mais garde
l'angle garde le plan parce que comme il
y a le petit Picot de bois je pense
qu'en tirant le nez
et en tournant complètement oh je suis
dans la non dis-moi quand je suis dans
le truc
et là je crois que je peux appuyer
quelque chose ah moi attends
[Musique]
il y a comme un ressort ou un truc
regarde ça fait vraiment bouger là ici
là quand j'enfonce ça fait rien mais
quand je ressors tu as vu ça bouge un
peu mais pourquoi tu tiens absolument à
remettre ça mais parce que en fait quand
je le mets je sens qu'ici il y a un
aimant qui s'agrippe à la vis et ça
m'énerve je me dis pas faire sortir
dans l'autre côté tout à l'heure là
quand tu faisais ton bail
carrément un truc qui bouge
[Musique]
gripper comme ça
ah oui
mais ça fait rien
parce qu'il faut pas refaire un truc de
avec
de ouf attends mais en appuyant là comme
je faisais tout à l'heure comme ça ah
oui là
non mais c'est ça il y a des étapes elle
a peut-être de nouveau ça
vient ça vient j'ai pas te mentir ça
bien merci de me prévenir ça vient ok on
essaie d'aller au bout
[Musique]
mais non
on peut pas
c'est un petit bonbon japonais ça va
c'est pas mal déjà
séquentiel et pas un exponentiel
est un casse-tête remonté
[Musique]
en moins d'une minute mais déjà bravo
une huit une neuf bravo
[Rires]
Fabien c'est un casque
merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
abonnez-vous à cette chaîne YouTube à
l'occasion ça fait toujours plaisir
lâcher un peu à très bientôt bel été à
vous ciao si vous voulez me voir en
spectacle à la rentrée il y a un lien
dans la description pour être prévenu
quand je passe près de chez vous ça fait
plaisir
[Musique]
et on se rend pas compte parce que mes
pattes avant